here are the facts in 2013 video games
are a sixty five billion dollar industry
they are totally awesome and playing
them is good for you
researchers at the University of
Rochester found students who didn't play
video games and divided them into two
groups they asked one group to play the
visually complex game Unreal Tournament
while the other played the relatively
simple not that that makes it a bad game
Tetris after a month of near daily
gaming the Unreal Tournament players
improved their vision by nearly 20% the
tetris players showed no improvement the
most difficult part of the study was
finding students who didn't play video
games in the first place
a lot of people mostly bombs say that
video games can rot your brain
but a neuro research lab at UC San
Francisco actually found the opposite to
be true they designed a video game
called neuro razor to Train cognitive
functions their study showed people from
ages 60 to 85 who played neuro racer
improve their multitasking and by the
end of the study some even had the
multitasking ability of a 20 year old
the researchers caution that you may not
be able to get these benefits from just
any video games so to make sure you're
covering your bases you're gonna want to
play every video game all of the time
a Deakin University study of
preschoolers found that those who played
interactive video games were better at
activities like throwing catching and
kicking in other words there is a
generation of all stars growing up right
now that is going to be amazing at both
video games and sports something you
will often hear gamers say is video
games can improve your reflexes but did
you know that it's actually true a study
from the University of British Columbia
found men who spend at least three hours
a week playing action video games had
better reaction times as well as
improved focus and stronger target
detection basically the stuff you need
to be an astronaut a baseball player or
a juggler you know anything cool
Plus which sounds much more impressive
when you find out that it stands for the
Public Library of Science recently
published a study that found surgery
students who spent a month playing games
like Wii tennis perform better and
hand-eye coordination tests so the next
time someone tells you that you're
playing too many video games send them
this video let them know you're training
to be a surgeon